if we sort of rewind back
and look at the the thing where we could
say something a little bit more
comfortably at five years and 10 years
out
you've written about jobs
and uh the impact on sort of our economy
and the jobs
in terms of artificial intelligence that
might it might have
it's a fascinating question what kind of
jobs are safe what kind of jobs are not
can maybe speak to your intuition about
how we should think about ai changing
the landscape of work
sure absolutely well this is a really
important question because i think we're
very far from artificial general
intelligence which is
ai that can just do the full breadth of
what humans can do
but we do have human level or superhuman
level
narrow intelligence narrow artificial
intelligence
and you know obviously my calculator can
do math a lot better than i can and
there's a lot of other things the
machines can do better than i can
so which is which we actually set out to
address that question
um with tom mitchell i wrote a a
paper called what can machine learning
do that was in science
and it we went and interviewed a whole
bunch of ai experts and
kind of synthesized what they thought
machine learning was good at and wasn't
good at
and we came up with we called a rubric
basically a set of questions you can ask
about any task that will tell you
whether it's likely to score high or low
on suitability for machine learning and
then we've applied that to a bunch of
tasks in the economy
in fact there's a data set of all the
tasks in the u.s economy believe it or
not it's called onet
the us government put it together bureau
of labor statistics
they divide the economy into about 970
occupations like
bus driver economist primary school
teacher radiologist
and then for each one of them they
describe which tasks need to be done
like for radiologists there are 27
distinct tasks
so we went through all those tasks to
see whether or not a machine could do
them
and what we found interestingly was
brilliant study weather that's
so awesome yeah thank you um so what we
found was
that there was no occupation in our data
set where machine learning just ran the
table and did everything
and there was almost no occupation where
machine learning didn't have like a
significant
ability to do things like take radiology
a lot of people i hear
saying you know it's the end of
radiology and one of the 27 tasks is
read medical images
really important one like it's kind of a
core job and machines have
basically gotten as good or better than
radiologists it was just an article in
nature last week but you know they've
been publishing them for the past few
years
showing that uh machine learning can do
as well as humans on many kinds of
diagnostic
imaging tasks but other things
radiologists do you know they
sometimes administer conscious sedation
they sometimes do physical exams they
have to
synthesize the results and explain to
the other
doctors or to the patients in all those
categories machine learning isn't
really up to snuff yet so
that job we're going to see some a lot
of restructuring um parts of the job
they'll hand over to machines others
humans will do more of that's
been more or less the pattern all of
them so you know to oversimplify a bit
we see a lot of restructuring
uh reorganization of work and it's real
going to be a great time it is a great
time for smart entrepreneurs and
managers to to do that reinvention of
work
i'm not going to see mass unemployment
to get more specifically to your
question the
kinds of tasks that machines tend to be
good at are a lot of routine problem
solving
mapping uh inputs x into outputs y
if you have a lot of data on the indexes
and the y's the inputs and the outputs
you can do that kind of mapping and find
the relationships
they tend to not be very good at for
even now
fine motor control and dexterity um
emotional intelligence and and
human interactions um and
thinking outside the box creative work
if you give it a well-structured task
machines can be very good at it
but even asking the right questions
that's hard there's a quote that
andrew mcafee and i use in our book
second machine age
apparently pablo picasso was shown an
early computer
and he came away kind of unimpressed he
goes well i don't see all the fusses
all that does is answer questions
and you know to him the interesting
thing was asking the questions yeah
try to replace uh me gpg3 i dare you
although some people think i'm a robot
you have this cool plot
that shows um i just remember where
economists landed
where i think the x-axis is the income
yes and then the y-axis is i guess
aggregating the information of how
replaceable the job is
or i think there's an incredibility for
machine learning index exactly
so we have all 970 occupations that's a
cool shot
and there's gathers and all in all four
corners have some
occupations but there is a definite
pattern which is the lower wage
occupations tend to have more tasks that
are suitable for machine learning
like cashiers i mean anyone's gone to a
supermarket or cvs knows that you know
they don't not only read barcodes but
they can recognize you and apple and an
orange
and a lot of things that cashiers humans
used to be needed for
um at the end of this other end of the
spectrum there are some jobs like
airline pilot that are among the highest
paid in our economy
but also a lot of them are suitable for
machine learning a lot of those tasks
are um and then yeah you mentioned
economist i couldn't help peeking at
those
and they're paid a fair amount maybe not
as much as some of us think they should
be
but um but they uh uh
have some tasks they're still for
machine learning but for now at least
most of the tasks that economists do are
didn't end up being in that category and
i should say i didn't like
create that data we just took the took
the analysis and that's that's what's
what came out of it and over time that
scatter plot will be
updated as as the technology improves
but um it was just interesting to see
the pattern there and it is
a little troubling in so far as if you
just take the technology as it is today
it's likely to worsen income inequality
in a lot of dimensions
you